-Guys, it is time
to announce the winner
of "The Tonight Show's
Fallon Summer Reads."
Here we go!
[ Band playing lively music ]
-♪ Summer Reads ♪
♪ Fallon Summer Reads ♪
-Now, here are the books
right here.
Now, uh, voting has ended.
The polls are closed.
-That's it.
-Don't even try to vote.
-Ugh.
-It's over. We know
who the winner is.
-You already know.
-Yeah. We already know, yeah.
We're announcing the winner
this evening -- right now.
We got hundreds
of thousands of votes.
This is our biggest voting
of any year, so far.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Big deal. Love that.
So, thank you
to everyone who voted,
and thank you
to all of our authors
for getting your enthusiasm,
getting involved in the contest,
and campaigning for your books.
These are all fantastic books.
They're all great.
Pick them all up, if you can.
Why not? Yeah.
But there can only be
one winner here.
It was a close race.
Yeah, just a few percentage
points separated these books.
All right, I'm gonna start
breaking it down for you.
[ Drum roll ]
♪♪
-Oh. Oh, snap.
Oh!
♪♪
[ Goofy voice ] Boy!
Ooh! [ Stammers ]
♪♪
Oh!
-"The Plot" is the book!
Congratulations!
That is this year's
"Fallon Summer Read"!
"The Plot" by
Jean Hanff Korelitz!
[ Applause ]
-Oh!
-So, here's how
this is gonna work.
Once again, I have not read
any of these books.
[ Laughter ]
But that is how
our book club works.
-Yeah.
-So, what I want to do
now -- this is our book.
I'm gonna read this book,
and I want us all
to read it together.
And then, follow us
on Instagram and Twitter
over the next few weeks.
I will be checking in,
letting you know
where I'm at in the book,
what I think so far.
And I want to know what you guys
think as you're reading, too.
So, use the hashtag
"#Fallon Summer Reads,"
and we'll talk
about it together.
Thank you to everyone who voted,
and congratulations
to "The Plot"
and Jean Hanff Korelitz.
We'll see you
on the show very soon.
Thank you, and congratulations.